Ah! So, 3 Monate kein Sport gemacht.
Jetzt hau ich richtig rein!
Ich kann mich nie wieder bewegen.
*Musik*
Martin Rocket möchte wissen, ob
Muskelkater gut oder schlecht ist.
Gute Frage, denn viele trainieren
nach dem Motto: No pain, no gain!
Sprich je größer der Muskelkater,
desto effektiver das Training, oder?
Über Muskelkater
kursieren viele Halbwahrheiten.
Zum Beispiel hört man immer wieder,
dass Muskelkaterschmerzen
von Milchsäure verursacht werden,
die bei sportlichen Belastungen
in unseren Muskeln gebildet wird.
Doch diese Theorie
wurde von Wissenschaftlern
weitestgehehd abgelehnt.
Ausgelöst wird Muskelkater v.a.
durch sogenannte
exzentrische Muskelübungen.
Beispiel Bizepsübung: das Hochziehen
der Hantel ist eine sogenannte
konzentrische Belastung.
Der Muskel zieht sich zusammen.
Die kontrollierte Rückwärtsbewegung
ist eine exzentrische Belastung.
Der Muskel wird gedehnt.
Und diese Kombi Ausdehnung
und Belastung ist besonders hart
für den Muskel.
Anderes Beispiel für exzentrische
Belastung: bergab laufen.
Wenn ihr es euch also mal richtig
hart geben wollt,
dann könnt ihr ja mal
mit Hanteln 'nen Berg runter laufen
und dabei ganz langsam
die Hand runterlassen.
In unseren Muskelfasern
werden das Strukturprotein Aktin,
und das Motorprotein Myosin
gegeneinander verschoben.
Diese Proteine hängen in einem
Gerüst, den sogenannten Z-Scheiben.
Und diese Z-Scheiben
fangen und federn die Bewegung
so'n bisschen ab.
Beim Muskelkater werden
diese Z-Scheiben aber beschädigt.
Schwellungen und Entzündungen
sind unter anderen die Folge.
Und die Schäden
müssen auch wieder repariert werden.
Das dauert seiner 1 - 2 Tage,
solange wir unseren Muskelkater
eben zu spüren bekommen.
Das ist aber kein Problem.
Muskelkater hinterlässt
keine bleibenden Schäden.
Aber hilft er denn
beim Muskelaufbau?
Gerade exzentrische Übungen
sollen tatsächlich
zu schnellerem Aufbau
von Kraft- und Muskelmasse führen.
Aber Forscher glauben, dass das
unabhängig vom Muskelkater passiert.
Bei regelmäßigem Training
mit langsamer,
stetiger Belastungssteigerung
kann man auch ohne Muskelkater
Kraft und Muskeln aufbauen.
Muskelkater ist eher nur
ein Signal dafür,
dass gewisse Muskeln gewisse
Bewegungen nicht gewohnt sind.
D.h. für: No pain, no gain! -
gibt es bisher keine
wissenschaftliche Belege.
Trotzdem darf man sich natürlich gut
fühlen, wenn man Muskelkater hat,
wenn's einen motiviert.
Schön schlau!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Martin, vielen Dank für deine Frage.
Wenn ihr noch Fragen habt,
schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Und: abonnieren nicht vergessen!